well
[Music]
how are you greetings by cristián cáceres with
his brief news now in
spanish a race on the 215 ended
with one person dead this happened
early monday the police say a
fight broke out between two drivers at
that moment one shot  towards the
other's vehicle causing it to
crash into a sector of
the airport building a man who was
behind the wheel died and a passenger
is in critical condition the
authorities are still on the trail of
the suspects an accident left one
person seriously  injured this happened
around nine thirty
Sunday night near craig and the
captain the driver is expected to
recover soon and today vice president
canela xerez will visit southern nevada
white house officials said
she will visit the area  of lake mead is
expected to speak about efforts
to combat climate change and
record kilograms of water level  up to
now issues of importance to the
bairén administration the
vice president will also try to address
the president's infrastructure plan
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have some breezes for
today reaching a maximum of 73 degrees
in the afternoon this has a week
The temperatures will rise to 80 we will continue
with a pleasant climate for next
week I am Cristian Cásseres with his
brief informative news now
Espanyol good day
[Music]